what up people we are about to watch
train to busan i don't want to watch
this movie for such a long time and as
promised after the squid game finale
that we would cover this one now if you
end up enjoying our video please go
ahead and hit that like button also make
sure to subscribe click the notification
bell got other movies in mind we want to
cover as well as always full length
watch long as we sync up with the time
code will be available over at our
patreon page cover a whole bunch of
shows over there as well we're at the
same time you get the option for both
reaction highlights and watch alongs
lastly thank you to prepper for aiming
down the highlights for us thank you so
much for clicking on this video
let's strap in
with the zombies let's do it
[Music]
do you hit an animal that would mess up
your truck though
tears
call somebody at least
what if the deer got back up careful
i think it's about to
did
is it
oh my goodness oh yeah
yes i'm dear
whoa cool
that's right
oh no
oh this is like resident evil
so
it's a gun lighter
this movie's dated
[Laughter]
should
[Music]
soil
so this movie's the little girl's fault
i want to see the cut where she does go
alone
but if you save her from a horde of
zombies you can become father of the
year man
reunite with your wife whole new life
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh you are you are not a good oh
god
not a good attendant
oh
what a curious little girl i know
oh god
get as far away from your dad as
possible when all this [ __ ] breaks out
that guy's super familiar
[Music]
just don't leave there the rest of the
trip
oh my god oh my god
oh my god
what a fast transformation yeah
everybody
panic panic now
[Music]
wow
there you are okay these transformations
are great whoa
damn
that's awesome
that's right by two people
or we're incredibly racist
oh no come on oh no come on guys no
she's pregnant come on
oh come on
yes okay
god smart
all right let's take a seat
it's all just right out this straight
ride
we'll see what else is on tv
[Laughter]
smith
but i have tickets to the opera
i better not be late because of this
i think the situation is probably really
bad over there yeah it's probably
already lost
oh god now i'm worried for her though
she's all alone
oh [ __ ]
oh
oh my
okay so this thing is airborne too it
seems like
well unless she got bit by somebody
oh
no
this movie is massively staged yeah it
really is
oh my god
oh
how'd that guy get that video up i know
you live streaming
still react to the fake news
what a shitty dad
oh man
i hope she survives yeah
[Laughter]
[Music]
you both made it
[Music]
why am i now afraid we're going to see a
zombie baby before this is over
i love how foreboding they've been
that's the exact word
this is like that's so foreboding you
know this is exactly what i was thinking
and so much of it is daylight and even
the daylight is like harsh
oh my god guys gives her a wrap get back
on the train
you're
don't get trapped by corridors and
escalators and other slow things that
cause you to bottleneck
get trampled
he cares about you he's trying to
protect you yeah
turn around
turn around
oh my god
this is the scariest zombie we've seen
in a while damn
no
no
[Music]
oh my god this guy's the [ __ ] this dude
dude
mvp of the movie right now
run
[Laughter]
yeah that was even bigger of a risk
what a solid grip of perspective
oh trust any door window corridor
doorway
you're in a paddock so you just like
open a door
whoa
no
[Music]
i'll call her granny oh
the contortionists they got for this are
top-notch too
oh the guy on either side of the zombies
on the train yeah oh [ __ ]
oh my god it's the worst oreo ever
yeah your friends are
[ __ ] up
no one's getting through those doors man
yeah it's overrun
oh wait what no wait wait no no don't
wait for that man
messing with
oh jesus
but then again we never really saw him
get on the trains
oh
oh hell no come on
come on buddy
what are you doing
what a boss
what who is this guy he's amazing this
dude is my favorite character i've seen
all year
you're gonna be a great dad
i hope you make your own real life man
you're the one i'm rooting for the most
no don't let the pregnant woman go let
the crazy homeless guy do it
oh
that's your shy clothes
trying to take shelter
oh no
no no no no no no no no
no
no
no
oh no
oh they're gonna have to like oh they
gotta work together now
they're all the same [ __ ]
didn't have to say what they were doing
this guy is the [ __ ] i love him so much
who is he
got him strapped up with the tape goblin
yes
yeah
removing the head or destroying the
brain damn look at him go
damn
oh
yeah identity go
oh do it you have no choice
and they're all kids so
it's not as hard
come on man
oh
so they're actually safe when the
tunnels are going yeah they waited for
her
they can't turn off the lights on the
train
is he making an investment
i was gonna distract them with the sound
yeah
like leave it in a chair behind or
something
oh yeah there you go buddy
[Laughter]
clever
foreign
[Music]
okay all right that's actually nice
god i hope he lives i can sacrifice the
kid
second kid pregnant wife that guy he's
got to make it
i'm the kid with a baseball bat
that's more sense
they got like two minutes yep they
better scurry
although uh
maybe it's not so bad from up there
[Music]
oh he's got a trip or something isn't he
oh god dammit
[Laughter]
though
yeah yeah
oh what a bunch of wow [ __ ]
[Music]
oh don't get your finger bit no
ah
chop that arm
wow
is
oh
oh no
oh
[Music]
oh this dude
[Music]
oh
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
fight it
[Music]
oh you [ __ ] your dicks
goddamn
[Music]
no
why no
oh
[Applause]
your dumb ass to start working at all
the other doors
[Laughter]
open the door oh
what
[Music]
[Laughter]
wow
this dude has no idea what's going on
i have hundreds of passengers on board
lives needs savings
[Music]
yeah this guy's been out of the loop
that time
or the first time he stopped was like
what the hell is going on
um
[Music]
that's so sad
ex-wife
they never forget
her new answer machine is her as a
zombie
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
what you don't realize is just one giant
ad for visiting busan that's right once
they get there it's going to be all
idyllic
bring your family
doesn't even need to close the door
close the door close the door
[Music]
oh no
[Laughter]
that's not what i was expecting
wow
close the door behind you
oh you dick
what a dick
[Music]
what a set piece
oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] yeah that's what i'm talking about
gotta get him they better do like this
don't help him he's like like you don't
know what you have no idea what's going
on this whole movie seriously my god
no
you gotta be kidding me
the worst character
no
[Music]
oh my god
even this guy's more heroic
oh
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh come on where's the military
bang bang
come on
most some of these guys down
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh no he's not gonna make the train is
he
oh he better
after all this he better oh he did
oh
oh no
no they're not
they're gonna stop the train
wow they're gonna pull that train to a
stop
oh my god they're like an ant hill
this is the craziest thing i think i've
seen in a zombie movie
oh
my man
wait till you see who's conducting the
train yes
what did you see who made it
[Music]
oh no
oh god
[Music]
chop that hand
that one dude caused such a ruckus
yeah
oh man it costs
most of the survivors
[Music]
not
[Music]
[Music]
yeah little girl so [ __ ] believable
korean child actors man
this is the best in the world
oh my goodness
[Music]
oh his life is flashing
oh
[Music]
[Music]
wow
[Music]
[Laughter]
what a shot
[Music]
[Music]
this goddamn cruise didn't make you
freaking power man
remember to bring a bottle of lighter
fluid to me everywhere
[Laughter]
might as well just do it it's good birth
right yeah
one trope i've been waiting on this
whole movie
let's just do it
the zombies learn how to shoot
training camp military zombies
do not know the living dead them do not
do that no
she got me shitty this is not happening
no
no
come on
come on
no get a little
oh
they man this little girl through the
ringer man
how did they achieve this performance
[Laughter]
oh
wow they just [ __ ]
i am i'm floored
let's watch the sequel now yeah
peninsula let's do it put it on
those are the best zombies i've ever
seen absolutely i've seen a lot of
zombie birds
that is that is one of the best ones
i've ever seen yeah that was that like
it had all the thrills and pulp but it
was totally affecting totally
dramatic
subtext without beating you in the face
with it
and i know some people are like how can
you tell they're good at acting you
don't know
[ __ ] man that was amazing
you know i had that thought only one
time during the movie and it was the
very beginning when the guy in the truck
says something out loud to himself
and then i was like i wonder
if just because it's not my language
because like those are usually the
hardest lines to sell is like a thing
you threw away to yourself but but yeah
like yeah there's a lot of tone and body
language so most of communication
absolutely yeah that is uh
if you want to
perform it's like a little girl
yeah that sounds like that seems like a
real little girl it's
a real most with harrowing most from me
yeah yeah
that was
so real i was like what the hell who is
this little girl in what direction did
they give her yeah
only what substitution did you give
did you
tell a little girl like your parents
died in real life
i just got the call that your dad's dead
yeah i'm sorry but we gotta get this
shot once we get the shot i'm so sorry
can you sing that really happy song we
had for you
korean cinema man
yeah gotta do snow piercer next and i
know how to get you in the fields while
giving you a lot of anxiety
yeah harrowing your soul at the same
time
while dragging you through the depths of
human darkness and despair light comedy
infusion
freaking measure where we've got to see
inside
i know
we don't know if the mom's alive
presumably not
i think it's safe to assume she's
probably dead let's talk about it yeah
yeah yeah
yep that was something that was
something yeah i i see why that movie
has been so hyped for so long that was i
have a list of movies i wanted to cover
and this was easily at the top of the
list
and um i get it
absolutely really get it lives up to the
hype it's got this uh just beautiful
handle on on build like it was one of
those movies where i was so enthralled
with the experience
while also studying like the
craftsmanship of filmmaking i was
watching it because
it just
[ __ ] with perspective so much and
the way it does build it just like
slowly becomes more metal
by the time it's like when they when you
get to the military and they're all just
dog piling on each other and the way
they even
build up the dog piling uh that's that's
just another little physical motif that
they it starts off on the train we're a
little bit of a dogfile they're like
whoa and the military's like whoa and
then by the end they're all just ringing
crawling they're like ants trying to get
on the train they just build up even
that dog pile and i think it's so it's
just so cool
but i i also think what obviously makes
us work so well beyond just great
direction is just really committed
nuanced characters and real acting you
know it's i love the way this all just
it just escalates you know it's it's
cool that they set it on the train as
they're setting and it's just about it
and you kind of feel like that is the
emotional momentum energy of this film
it's just this train that is like as
this situation is becoming derailed
yeah
you you can see that with the characters
happening too like i i love by the how
they don't understand what's going on so
there or even ends up being a separation
of the groups when one group decides to
be heroic
yeah like you might be infected like you
kind of get where they're coming from
but then it's pretty evident at a
certain point where they're pretty
peaceful and chill yeah they're not
infected and you guys have seen enough
of how the infected works i i would
think so to see how quick they would
turn yeah that um but they're just so
hyper paranoid by that moment
and um
yeah but yeah john what'd you think that
was uh it was quite a foreboding
tense yeah man it was a ride to say the
least uh i loved it it was like i said
really lived up to the hype and yeah i i
think they had a masterful way of really
gradually introducing the situation
while you know putting seeds of it in
from like the very first moments it's
like even when uh his assistant guy is
coming into the first uh part of the
movie and saying like oh hey you know
there's been an incident over here and
you know like there's some kind of
problem with this biotech lab and like
all these little things that are
building and yeah especially the outset
when they're in the train station
they're boarding the train i loved the
way that they orchestrated the timing
because it is like you know they get
like he's taken his daughter on the day
he didn't want to go back home and it's
like perfectly time so where they're
just missing all the sort of building
chaos right behind them as like i love
when they get on the train and the you
know attendant guy goes to look up the
stairs and there's already some kind of
disturbance happening when a little girl
sees a guy get tackled but because of
the window it's not really audible for
her yeah yeah and you can't really see
the entirety of the context there even
though we know it as the audience and
then you know once you finally get like
a glaring spitting blood spewing zombie
like it it builds to that point and then
it's such a punch when it finally
happens and i think the train setting is
so perfect because i mean you know there
are a lot of places to do zombie movies
and you know there are zombies on a
plane which i've heard is fun but
there's something about the train
specifically that makes for a really
terrific bottle that can be very long
and and present a lot of obstacles but
then can also get you back on the ground
pretty easily and create tension that
way well yeah it's an isolated
environment however
it's also because it's moving and it
complements the fact that it's a
fast-moving train complements the speed
and the ferocity of and how uh and how
the zombies themselves actually move
yeah so it's a cool visual
complementation that's happening in that
one
and just this whole setting that they
have here well in the outbreak too
because then you think like this train
is like i don't know if it's a bullet
train but it looks like it's moving
really fast and you're like man you're
also right now you're also building
either way though like you're building
this paranoia of okay there are certain
other stops that are closed and we can
only stop in these couple places it
looks like we can only stop to busan and
they do a really nice job of building
you've already got enough paranoia in
the room but it's also the paranoia of
like what is the outside world gonna be
you know other than what we know is
probably just a lot of destruction yeah
you know for the character's perspective
there's so many angles to drive up that
fear and anguish and just to put you in
their shoes and disorient you you know
yeah it was great
yeah and like great memorable characters
too like uh what's his name ma dong seok
we have his name pulled up here yeah
that's how you say it from uh who
gilgamesh is not the character's name no
no no no no no no no no no no that's
yeah
well i think a lot of movies would take
the time at least in the us when it
comes to zombie movies they would take
the time to
like explain everyone's background but i
loved how they handled it with him that
you just pick up on
he is
he's not as frantic as everyone else
yeah that doesn't mean he's not on edge
and taking the situation seriously he's
not just like too cool for school here
but you get this sense of like he has
some type of maybe military maybe some
type of fighting background he's like
trying to get his life clean and he's
got a he's got a baby along the way you
know there's something that and he
doesn't look kindly upon the kind of
profession
that uh the the gong you character has
uh
you know so it's he's not as privileged
you could tell he had like how to grow
up in the rough life but they don't do
any dialogue to like tell you about that
but they just let that be unveiled with
this guy as it goes and it just makes
him such a badass yeah like when he's
running and he just grabs the shield and
takes out some guys and hops on the
train and then all right let's leave the
charge and he just straps himself up
while they got weapons and he's just
using his fists yeah
it's it is a really cool character and
he's also like funny and charming at the
same time yeah absolutely i think it's
really yeah clever the way that you it's
just conscientious i think is a better
word the way you meet most of the
characters on the train through as much
yeah as you would get from just their
body language and piecing things
together about them and i think some
people would call that a lack of
character development but i don't know i
prefer it to i feel like if this was an
american-made movie all of our important
characters might get some kind of quick
flashback to just establish they got a
family or they got some kind of other
ties outside well they thrust you into
the immediacy of the situation so
there's no time for any of the
conversations no but but two i think and
maybe it is the language barrier but
even just reading it doesn't seem like
it's written the same way a lot of
american zombie movies are where there's
like okay we gotta check in with our
character types even though the
character types are all here um or at
least many extent you know yeah but
they're way more i think the greedy dude
who is just a as i think it was
appropriate to have him be the
the the villain of the humans
uh because in a lot of ways our our main
guy seemed like he was destined to sort
of end up being this could
yeah totally like they paid such great
attention to detail honestly like uh i
was
as much as i was like thinking okay this
arc's a little bit predictable that
they've set him up as this selfish
greedy dude only looks out for himself
and it's like you gotta just look out
for yourself
the
as predictable as the ark was
i was still like i'm not sure i could
get on board with this guy he seems like
too much of an [ __ ] in my opinion
like the main guy and then he just had
me so like halfway through and
the way they show how he becomes more
caring and i think
it's kind of neat to watch squid game
which is from completely i know the main
guys in that show in a couple of
episodes but to watch squid game and to
watch this and also feel like i got some
similar compliments to throw their way
where the the arc isn't in through
dialogue where they're like i learned
not to be selfish because of you thank
you for teaching me but you see the
situation like he starts off
antagonistic with the mandang
character um not antagonistic but a bit
at odds with each other uh because of
this the selfish choice that he made but
then uh to not let him through the door
at
first however as when is when the
daughters kidnap them they start working
together you you start seeing the
changing character there well you start
seeing how how quickly your thrust
between both positions of being the one
who could close the door and the one who
could hold it open or who needs it to be
held open you know well you he starts
off selfish and he's
progressively becoming
less selfish yeah yeah right from
helping him onto the train getting
across the train uh just really looking
at like helping out other individuals
even helping out the
the crazy looking homeless dude who i
liked what they did with him too because
like i i've got a whole story going on
you got a whole story
and i do appreciate when movies do that
where it's like i can tell this actor's
got a story going i can tell whoever
made this and wrote this you know knows
who all these people are and and they
make i thought a nice mystery out of
that character because
a lot of the time you know you're you're
a little suspect of him and i feel like
there's a certain amount where you could
go like what is he involved with this
somehow or is he like patient zero or
something like what's going on but uh
yeah just like the amount of nuance they
were still able to capture with all that
and i like that it's a zombie movie
where like you have a lot of the themes
of like you know fear and paranoia are
you know the outbreak you mentally in
these situations are you know the sort
of driving force of the rabid horde but
moreover the movie seems to want to like
i feel like a lot of zombie movies touch
on the theme
in a scene but this movie sort of made
it the overarching theme is yeah when
you should look out for others versus
when you should reach for
self-preservation first you know yeah i
mean they have a great character and
this gong you actor man like he's
phenomenal terrific he's phenomenal like
again i i love a good performance where
it's all in the body language and
just so much of the performance in his
eyes you know i started getting a little
this random thought popped into my head
i i sort of and i i don't know why i
drew this comparison uh i i started
thinking like i don't get this like
old school almost like asian jimmy
stewart thing about him okay
or it's like a reserved performer where
it's all kind of just in the looks and
the subtleties
but because every time i've seen this
actor he's in a suit
there's something that feels like
old-school hollywood about him yeah
or
yeah because he is he is such a subtle
actor and um it is all in this like
rough around the edges but
as much of an [ __ ] as they present
him to be
initially you could tell underneath the
surface there's a sympathetic individual
so that's kind of why i drew that
comparison and and i really do like uh
like everything that he he did here like
man i was uh i was really moved by the
end with it when he sacrificed himself
oh absolutely well and that's the thing
too is like you started out and you're
like yeah you know he's he's way too
he's he's busy he's got a lot of work to
do he's maybe not the best dad but it
didn't seem
as cliche as i've seen that a million
times where it's like ah he sucks like i
could totally see he's such an [ __ ]
huh yeah yeah i'm like it seems like
he's overworked and he's got a lot of
responsibility well his ass whole
qualities
uh bleed through in the in the private
moments yeah not so much in public
conversations yeah you know what i mean
other than when he's kind of being like
a bit of a cutthroat um boss at the
beginning he's not like overly doing it
yeah or even like with his daughter he
pulls her away like hey just between you
and i and just being so [ __ ] good
yeah yeah it's gonna get you killed have
you seen a zombie movie
your mom showed you a zombie movie yeah
and yeah and you also do see how much he
really does love his daughter like right
from the right from the start yeah
oh yeah absolutely i felt so bad with
the wish
poor guy but that but the the pregnant
wife was also really great the the
little girl sue and kim holy [ __ ] yeah
is that her suing him we got imdb pulled
up here
uh
whoa insane like who is she insanely
good performance
how did they god she
shattered my soul
no
like like i would put that up against
any performance you know it's weird it's
like there's sometimes and not to be a
dick but like you know sometimes you
kind of asked to risk he's like oh this
is a good child performance where i was
just like that was just a great
performance real real [ __ ] human
performance yeah i mean in terms of like
the actual movie itself i mean all the
performances were were freaking
phenomenal but i really think like the
directing is is like a the big star of
this movie on top of everything
because the framing device is used all
around it was the closest to visually
realizing
kind of what i've wanted for them to
adapt a resident evil movie to be like
yeah i know we got a resident evil movie
coming um that is inspired by the first
two games but what i mean by that is
like one thing i loved about how that
first game was was shot was how you kind
of walk into frames and the way you do
the reveals through the frames if you
guys have played the first game it's
it's it's really eerie very cinematic
very unsettling of how you just walk
into the next shot and there's a zombie
there yeah yeah yeah you should open the
door
yeah
it's not um it's not as obvious in the
way it does or there's not predictable
jump scares and then here the way they
did that like even right down to the
final one of the final shots in the
movie when they are running towards the
train it looks like oh there's like six
zombies running towards them and then as
the camera just keeps going while you're
back then there's like more zombies and
more zombies more zombies and they have
a lot of cool revealing shots uh pretty
much throughout here and i thought the
way they
captured their zombies too
felt very
like
tangible in the way they they they're
presented like it really does have a
good blend of just
weird well hey i love how when they're
infected they're like messed up and then
these yeah like kind of like a tortoise
insane some of them especially some of
them like wrathing around on the ground
and then getting up to their feet with
their arms like wrapped around their
hands and stuff like yeah i like the way
they were realized and uh they didn't go
like
too extreme with the way the
transformation was
it's pretty much in the job of the
actors
and all the background players and then
yeah of course like good makeup good uh
good eye makeup too
um but it wasn't like overdone where
they're like completely just falling
aboard yeah yeah they're they're they're
very much like 28 days later zombies
yeah yeah i would say because they're
even durable it's like when he's trying
to beat him off the train at the end
it's like that skin's not coming apart
well they knew how to handle a good
horde
when it was um they're just so extreme
in quantity and uh how visceral they
would go
but
so they knew when to like implement like
visual effects versus practical but then
a lot of times it was like man how what
is the blend here of stuntman versus so
that's what i mean i would sometimes get
like a little pulled out in a good way
of just admiration for the filmmaking
i'm watching this yeah yeah there wasn't
anything i didn't like you know i i
think the one thing that just on a
personal
thing that i hated
not hate it i think i'm supposed to hate
it it's just how that
the the dude who you hate
just kept getting away
yeah which is like uh damn it it was
like even right down to the train
conductor coming out there to save his
ass
and it's just like the drinking doctrine
gets
taken while he gets to board the train
you know yeah
they give you one guy to really root
against yeah in a movie where it's not
really about that as much he is like the
one guy well all these movies have like
uh infected or [ __ ] of some type of
supernatural creature there they always
they tend to have the one he's the guy
and not a living dead who doesn't want
them to go in the basement and who wants
to be in charge he's like all riser and
aliens yeah
he's just that guy in the genre yeah
well and and i will say that despite
that i think that just across the board
in the scripting and the direction this
had i i know it like at the very
beginning we were kind of laughing about
like oh you didn't notice that that girl
like run onto the train but for the most
part every development and all the
pacing felt very conscientious and felt
very natural and it didn't feel like it
was
trying to hit tropes or satisfy beats
that we know like if it really just
propelled itself straight forward and
really committed to the drama
and sometimes the drama is action-packed
you know but of the situation well this
movie only took one moment to be cool
and that's when they just decided to go
across the train and yeah
yeah like that that was a timer it was
like oh we're kind of like a badass
action movie now yeah exactly but they
know how to they know how to implement
obstacles uh very well like
uh the way they handle the the tunnel
sequence like i love how they go okay we
need light so we'll go when we're past
the tunnel and then that tunnel ends up
being their advantage yeah but the way
they're like hi dodge like they really
everything just feels so choreographed
so immediate too yeah it's so well
thought out and like everything you just
it's such a great like map this this
script has you know like i love when the
lights come on he's picking up the
homeless guy he's just like pushing like
they made light like really jarring in
this movie like light starts to feel
less and less safe yeah yeah which i
love which you know which is great it
was weird for a zombie movie yeah which
i think is a beautiful contrast that's
something i've always crafts like i want
to make a horror movie where like light
daylight is the thing that makes you
dread yeah you know almost and to a
degree they do that here yeah and then
even have they haven't and then have to
uh crawl across the compartments yeah
smart it's all it's all well just
thought out and again like other
perspective shots that stand out to me
are when they are going down the stairs
they think they've made it to their
haven you know and then
as the camera just goes down more you're
like okay i see military outfits just
standing there what's going on okay
just turn around
yeah well and there are a few of those
reversal moments throughout the movie
that just make your stomach plummet yeah
it's really well and this is like a
fantastically executed film and as a fan
of the zombie genre and
in states where i feel like the zombie
genre they're always like
trying out
like new
action or comedy versions new ways to do
it but to also pay homage to every great
one that you guessed for yeah and i like
a lot of them um
but
it was nice to just see an actual
zombie horde horror movie that feels
like a true horror of true horror that
was actually scary and and and truly
intense and uh
like appropriately violent at the same
time uh very character-driven i'm like
damn you know you know what i'm saying
about a lot of zombie movies out here
these days at all often times they don't
have to be they just gotta have like
personality but like yeah i didn't
expect to be crying at the end of the
day yeah i was really hooked into the
dropped yeah yeah i thought they i
thought this is one of the absolute best
zombie movies i've ever seen yeah and i
and i really cared throughout about at
least the characters that we got
attached to i even cared when the
vagrant guy died like sacrificed himself
and died like that's a character you
might you know not really care as much
about but even he had presents to me and
then you know you have a couple people
who you start to actively root against
but i i even there's one scene that
stood out to me where they are having
that confrontation with everybody in the
cabin
right as you're watching i think that
was one of the most beautiful character
moments is when you're watching the
paranoia start to spread as they're
deciding whether or not to kick
everybody who just tried to save
everybody in the back of the train to
you know the vestibule or whatever like
that
and then slowly they all start to kind
of vocally be like no you got to get out
of here like that was a beautiful visual
representation of the drama underneath
all this you know oh yeah then also with
um was gong you was his name yeah and
then watching as he's just reacting to
it that's what i mean man the guy has
such a great subtlety about him because
he's not like fighting
they're so he's just watching this
happen he's just observing as they're
all turning and he gives just that one
little like
yeah that scoff of course of course
after all this you guys are gonna but
odds are if the roles were reversed you
might have been on that side and that's
right and yeah yeah and that's a lot of
people probably might i like yeah i
understood the choice it was the
uh you know like you're so mad at them
when they're doing it but uh at the same
time it does reach a point where you're
like
cut it out yeah guys come on here's my
my threshold for understanding you even
if
because it's like it's clear they're not
infected yeah
and if they
but they can they don't understand yeah
you know at the same time they do such a
good job at painting
the movie
wants you to root against them in that
moment of course they do
who would say
i mean but come on i mean if you're in
that position wouldn't you be also kind
of paranoid to be infected well yeah of
course but in terms of the movie they're
making they want you to root against
them that's why they paint that guy like
such a horrible dude yeah yeah and then
it's all the more maddening when the
dude who actually works on the train
just like won't speak up or anything and
just keeps on selling that guy's line
like yeah and then he gets you know fed
to the zombies first opportunity
hoping that our dude would make it uh i
was i was yeah and then of course the uh
yeah like the i like the teenagers
they managed to make you really care
about that too like i like the way they
handle that romance of
it's like high school boy girl and crush
of like i like you leave me alone and
then yeah you really like you really did
like her back yeah they fight for each
other yeah you know throughout the movie
he just let himself get killed
she died in his arms and
yeah it was a good it was a damn good
movie i was i was uh it's rare where a
movie lives up to the hype it's such an
extent
where you don't i
don't know anything about it so then to
see
like what it actually does yeah it
didn't go oh i get it you want to be
sitting here with
an equal amount of like this badass
crazy scary zombie action moment and
then this character bit like even the
thing with old lady when she lets
everybody in when she's like you're so
what did you do this for why'd you
sacrifice yourself for these people uh
uh like there's yeah this was a this is
a special one in the zombie
umbrella i feel like as far as zombie
cinema goes yeah
all right raccoon city
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below
uh thank you everyone who's recommended
this over the years
um we've got other films to check out
too
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button and hey let's do a pic
andrew hayes
andrew mcmahon has just gone back from a
trip
where he went to a bachelor party
got messed up
and he's also got a short film that's
gonna be in a film festival right now
dude so andrew you have been killing it
dude killing it but knowing your luck
while your film is premiering at the
film festival
bam ah what do you think i'm going with
this john oh
a zombie outbreak happened that's where
i'm going yeah take it away oh and then
what you got
you gotta get back to all your friends
who uh you like to hang out with and
you know you're gonna have to encounter
so many different types of people and
you being a lock person guy who works
with keys you could be a useful member
of a team of survivors but also people
are going to try and form alliances with
you and maybe double cross you and
whatnot so you got to keep on your toes
andrew hayes surviving the snowpocalypse
more like surviving a viral outbreak
am i right
thanks andrew thanks